this is a production of cornell
university
okay
all right everybody we're going to get
our pest management section started
i'm going to be your first speaker
my name is lynn cisnewski and i am an
assistant professor here at cornell
agritech in geneva in the horticulture
section
and i'm focused on weed management in
specialty crops and this includes hemp
so i want to talk to you a little bit
about
hemp and and weed management and why
it's such a problem and what kind of
strategies we have in place
currently and what we can expect to have
in the near future i think if you can
you turn it up hit the plus a bit
try that again okay is that better okay
yeah
all right so i'm going to talk about uh
weeds and weed management and hemp and
i've heard from a lot of growers
a lot of different cce specialists that
one of the limiting factors for hemp
production
is is weeds and the and the competition
from weeds and that's in part because we
don't have any registered synthetic
herbicides for use in the commodity like
we do in
you know our agronomic systems or
horticultural crops or ornamental crops
now on the flip side of that and we'll
talk about that in the second part of my
talk is it's probably going to be a
little bit hard to get some of those
synthetic products because hemp is
extremely sensitive
to a lot of different active ingredients
and modes of action
so i know you don't have the the paper
handouts but i'm going to go over what's
on mine today
and talk a little bit about the research
we're doing and just best management
practices
for weed control and then talk about the
herbicide work that we're doing and then
talk about the herbicide injury that
we've seen
okay so first and foremost we are
actively involved in researching weeds
weed control
in hemp
i along with colleagues from north
dakota state university virginia tech
southern illinois university and clemson
university received a usda
m grant to look at hemp competitiveness
with weeds
and to evaluate different weed
management strategies different cultural
and physical weed management strategies
as well as some chemical products we are
in the first year of our trial so i
don't have data to share
i will have that for next year's hemp
programs though one thing i can tell you
is that hemp is sensitive
to weed competition
you know there's a lot going around
saying that hemp is a competitive crop
you know that you know it's not going to
need a lot of
management of unwanted vegetation and
certainly for the cbd hemp that is not
true we need to
probably keep it at least weed free
about four to six weeks
to give it a chance to to maximize
yields
uh you know and and that's uh that's
that's a long time when you don't have a
lot of tools available to you again
preliminary work but right now that's
what our data is showing
ah
so we are a tag team yeah so if if you
want a little bit more information what
i am talking about there's a qr code
that you can scan and that's going to
bring up the handouts actually i just
tested it it does not bring up the
handout it brings up the website for
this meeting
and then you see lynn sosnoski and
that's where you click on for the
handout and then you get to the
beautiful handout and then you get
there's two beautiful handouts there
should be everyone wants to scan my code
raise your hand and i'll bring it around
right so
barring the the availability of
herbicides we got to really focus on
integrated weed management and the first
of two handouts that i i've provided
through your qr code
talk about integrated weed management
and actually give you links to two very
good integrated weed management sites
the one is called
integratedweedmanagement.org
that gives a bunch of information about
you know basic best management practices
and then the second is a website
uh that links to a book that the late
chuck muller from cornell university put
together it is a free book through ser
it is absolutely wonderful
and it's manage weeds on your farm and
ecological approach and i'm telling you
you want to go and you want to download
that pdf it is
perhaps one of the best free resources
you are going to get for weed management
but to kind of summarize what both of
those sites are saying when it comes to
weed management and hemp first and
foremost if you have the ability
to choose your sites that you're going
to plant your hemp crop into
you definitely want to to do that you
want to choose your fields wisely so if
you have fields that have perennial
weeds like field bindweed like canada
thistle or you have very high weed
densities if you have the ability to
avoid those fields you want to avoid
those fields because you want to start
off with as low a weed pressure
as possible when you're putting a crop
in that you don't have chemical control
strategies
if you have the ability to adjust your
planting date
if you know you have a weed and you know
it gets up early or it gets up late and
you can adjust your planting date to
either avoid that weed species or to
give the hemp a competitive edge against
that weed species consider
changing your planting date
you can use stale seed bed practices and
that's where you go in and you actually
stimulate weed seeds to germinate in
advance of your planting whether it's
with irrigation whether it's with
rainfall whether with it's a timely
cultivation and then you go in and you
destroy the weeds that get up to try and
exhaust that initial seed bank
choosing good seed quality and using
appropriate seeding rates
if you know that you know certain
varieties have rapid and even
germination getting a stand up evenly
getting a stand up rapidly is going to
be so important and that's going to
actually play into my
second part of my talk about herbicides
i did not have a good seed lot this year
i didn't get even germination i didn't
get a good stand
i had a lot of weeds and not only that
the poor stand quality the poor seed
quality affected the hemp response to
the herbicides and i saw a lot more
injury than i expected to
with transplants transplants help you
maximize the height
differential between the crops and the
weeds and that is going to help improve
the competitiveness so if you can put
transplants in they're already up before
your weeds get up and they can get
established get over that transplant
shock quickly
get them established it's going to put
you ahead with cultivation
where you are cultivating keeping your
rows as straight as possible because
that is going to improve your ability to
get in tight with the row when it comes
to cultivation events and it's going to
reduce the potential for crop damage by
if if your row is waving and then you're
going straight taking out
plants with your cultivation
plastic mulches
managing the the weeds between the rows
and in the planting holes is still
really important we've got a trial out
at the farm right now where we're
managing
weeds in the holes and we're just
letting them go and we're seeing real
differences even those few weeds that
get up in the hole are enough to really
compete with the hemp
and then minimizing weed seed spread so
this is just good cleanliness making
sure
if you're working in fields work your
cleanest fields first don't go from an
exceptionally weedy field and carry that
mud or carry chaff or straw or whatever
material
into your cleanest field you know try
try to always work cleanest to
weediest
so
we talked about
integrated weed management strategies
now we're just going to go into the
herbicides because everybody does ask
about herbicides when are we getting a
herbicide when are we going to get a
herbicide
there is there are products moving
through the epa there are products
moving through the ir4 project which is
uh specializing in bringing
chemical technology to
specialty crops or or low acreage crops
so i have been told that at the floralin
sauna land should be coming
on the market soon it's on the market it
should be having hemp on its label soon
it was in the spring it's now been
pushed back to the fall
so be on the lookout for saunaland it is
a group three
so it's the same chemical family as
trifluralin it's the same chemical
family as pentamethylene
all right it tends to be a bit stronger
on grasses than it is on broad leaves i
am going to tell you i have seen some of
the label language for ethyl fluorine we
did a bunch of work with pendimethalin
this year prowl h2o
and we got a lot of rain and we saw a
lot of damage
because we basically sort of flooded our
fields if you're going to have a
situation where you do have flooding or
you're going to potentially be getting a
lot of rain you're going to have the
same potential issues with ether
floralin which is going to be stem
swelling and root damage
but it is coming on the market
uh there's another product a grass
herbicide uh quiz elephant it goes under
a ashore too
it is also on in trials and i believe
amvac is very interested in supporting
uh this chemistry in hemp
and then there's a lot of interest and
more important than just
researcher interest there's also i
believe company interest in a product
called tuperolate
it is a group 27 hppd inhibitor
and there's work again going on through
the ir4 project looking at superolate
now toperolate and the short two are
going to be
further down the pipeline than at the
floralin which we're anticipating very
soon
with respect to pre-emergence herbicides
i did put in a couple of pre-emergent
herbicides trials this year looking at a
number of products at two different
rates they expand a bunch of different
chemical classes and i'm going to tell
you
it wasn't good uh hemp is really
sensitive to a lot of herbicides and
again i had a very poor seed lot and i
think that kind of enhanced the damage i
saw even the products that i was
expecting to see much more safety with
such as sandia which is halo sulfuron or
dual magnum which is esmentolocor i
still saw too much damage too much crop
loss again i think due to the seed lot
the other thing is we are looking at
herbicides for use in transplanted hemp
so it would be put down prior to
transplanting
and uh again
saw more injury than i wanted to see had
some really good weed control but too
much crop stunting
again we did have a lot of rainfall and
that could have enhanced the results we
saw
another thing that we saw it's not just
what happens with the root zone when
we're talking these pre-emergent
herbicides we transplanted and we had a
driving rain and driving wind
and we had our hemp transplants touch
the ground where we had just put our
herbicides down
and we burned a lot of hemp
you know that we weren't anticipating
you know 40 mile an hour winds to come
through so understand that some of these
products in addition to potentially
causing root damage if you have
transplants and they get wilted or you
have those driving rains
those driving winds and you get the the
leaf contact
with the soil surface you can also have
injury
i'm not going to go into it but i talked
that hemp is really sensitive to a bunch
of herbicides the second handout is
actually hemp responses
uh to some post-emergence herbicides so
in the case of drift events i actually
have gotten a lot of drift calls is this
herbicide injury is this herbicide
injury is this herbicide injury
and so things like dicamba 24d
glyphosate some of the other products
and so i've just put some pictures and
talked a little bit about the modes of
action and the kinds of symptomology
that you can expect to see i am working
currently on a herbicide
injury website that's going to go up at
cornell cals this fall and it will have
a lot of hemp pictures in it because
hemp again is really sensitive to a lot
of herbicides
and that is my talk and i'm going to
pass it off to chris unless you've got
questions
yes
question
yeah i think the lack of herbicides now
is kind of an opportunity for us to
really get good at uh things like
mechanical cultivation
so can you tell me what your experience
with hemp is in mechanical cultivation
is it sensitive to
its root level and mechanical stuff
so i've worked with transplanted hemp
and cultivation and i have not seen
sensitivity to the cultivation event
itself my problem is is that the
cultivation not getting between the hemp
plants
well enough and still leaving too
many with the cultivation system that
we're studying
still leaving too many
too many weeds present and and still
allowing for too much
competition
the
i did not have the cultivator that i
wanted because of supply chain issues
but we now have it so now i do have
a actually a vision guided cultivator
that follows the rose much better has
some better implements on it that i
think is going to get us a lot closer
than
what we're
about
using
we're uh we're still looking at a fairly
shallow depth like an inch
i have a question yes so since
hemp is so sensitive to herbicide if you
already have weeds
established what do you recommend to do
well it's going to depend what hemp
you're growing if you've got the ability
to to cultivate
using cultivation it's also going to
very much depend on
you know maybe a high value you know a
cbd hemp where you can get in there and
invest in hand weeding
you know it's a lot of time it's a lot
of effort and it's a lot of money
but yeah we don't we don't have a lot of
strategies there is some work that has
been done out at nebraska looking at
flame weeding
uh steve knezevek
has got some information online about
flame readers again we were supposed to
do flame weeding but because of supply
chain issues i do not have my flame
leader it is still coming so we are
going to be investigating
flame weeding next summer we do have our
new cultivator so we're going to have a
much better ability to get a lot closer
to the crop
and uh again also i i have
i've got some more tools coming it's
just
kova delays has is is playing into a
couple of years about just row covers i
know it's probably a lot of scale but
like plastic
plastic
yeah oh yeah
so
i we're using weed cloth sorry can you
repeat oh he asked about weed cloth so
she had asked the question what if you
already have weeds up
in the ground yeah so
finding really good control with the
plastic or the weed cloth but we are
finding that you've got to still be very
actively managing in the holes it takes
a lot less effort maybe to do those
plants but
letting those plants go we're still
seeing significant yield loss if we
don't go in there and control the weeds
that are coming up through the planting
hole in the plastic
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu